okay guys Mary here along with Justin at
TGS 2015 and we just got to check out
the brand new expansion for blood-borne
the old antennas yes so they're showing
off the new expansion for the game here
and I think the main proximate was
focusing on the new weapon so there are
three new weapons that we got the
traffic's expansion one was a win a bow
and arrow and a kind of a bladed weapon
that so makes him a chainsaw and a sword
looks like it was devised by cookie ve
when I put in this game and I saw I
tried out one of those I tried out the
song because it was the most familiar I
think we're gonna see a lot of people
play with that one it's kind of heavy
and does a lot of damage but some of the
more interesting ways that you can use
the lighter weapons or the bow and arrow
and the whip it's always fascinating to
see how blood-borne Desiree in weapons
you don't see a lot of that and when you
do it's typically in a gun so to see a
bow and arrow is really fascinating so
tell me a little bit about that and then
the trick mode of that something the bow
itself is lets you do some long-range
attacks it does it seems like it does a
little bit more damage at a longer range
than a gun which is something that'll
feel like one more was missing going to
trip 02 gives you a blade it's not quite
as heavy as some of your bigger swords
but is a little bit lighter and faster
than the really big heavy sword so it's
kind of a good mix of those two things
while still letting you keep ranged
attacks and it keep enemies far away and
then the other weapon is also kind of an
interesting mix to whip it can do some
pretty heavy damage when you're close up
but it's also kind of a good area of
attack effect and like not only wiping
out big groups of enemies but if you do
kind of get surrounded there's too many
people around you then your ility is the
web get some space get get clear
everyone around your anything when you
can use it in a powerup stance it can
actually go circle and kind of get a lot
of people around you as opposed to just
a direct forward attack which is pretty
nice now a lot of times in the blend
born games are known for having these
large open expansive worlds we kind of
picked the direction you want to go but
in this demo it seems like the kind of
how to set path for you to go where did
it lead it so this one might have been
set up just for this demo though I don't
know if this is actually a final part of
the game but of course it's going to
lead to a boss we got to try out that
seem amalgamation of like weird creepy
heads and a horse dog body they you
expected a blood-borne at level and of
course he lives in a big pool
and so you're running around just what
is shooting up everywhere as he comes
and raises hand down thank you it was
absolutely disgusting any of that close
up on the faces like I they just get
those faces that make you [ __ ] too sick
to your stomach so well in that really
awesome way blood-borne is known for
invoking a sense of dread and discussed
but you just keep going at it so in
terms of the difficulty level about the
same level with special for him it's
been a little while since I played
blood-borne so it was definitely hard
getting back into it but the difficulty
level is definitely where you'd expect
it to be for these kind of games and
especially trying out some Dark Souls
earlier this week it's it's on par with
what you expect from a new blood-borne
expansion and there were so many hunters
here to face off against in the Civil if
that's any indication of what you're
gonna have to face in the game and the
little bit scared about getting back
into it what's so exciting to see what
else they're gonna show for it we just
got our first taste of the old hunters
and it's already looking amazing so I'm
really excited about it and for
everything else teaching else related be
sure to stay tuned the games club
you